Hello guys, and welcome back to
yeagerists! In today's video we
will be going through the story of Levi
Ackerman "HUMANITY'S STRONGEST SOLDIER"
Levi is the son of Kuchel Ackerman, a
prostitute who worked in the Underground
and was made pregnant by one of her
clients. One day, Kenny Ackerman,
Kuchel's older brother, came to the city
to see her only to find that she was dead.
There, he found a young and squalid Levi
sitting in front of his mother's bed.
In a rare showing of compassion, Kenny decided
to take care of him. He raised Levi as well as
he could: teaching him knife skills, how to get
along with people, and violent behavior. Levi
also learned to use his own inner power that
he possessed as a member of the Ackerman clan.
Time passed and eventually, Kenny
taught Levi everything he knew. However,
he did not consider himself as a good father
figure. One day, in the subterranean city,
Levi started a fight which he won easily. At
that moment, Kenny decided to leave him behind,
satisfied that he had taught Levi
the skills he needed to survive.
Later, he became a notorious thug in
the underground but eventually left
the place to join the Survey Corps.
Although he was at odds with Erwin,[30]
he ended up becoming one of his most trusted men.
Levi is seen leaving Trost District,
along with the rest of the Survey Corps,
on the 56th Expedition Beyond the Walls—the same
day the Colossus Titan attacks the district.
While on the expedition, Levi sees a soldier
caught in the jaws of a nearby Titan and kills it.
As more Titans approach, Levi orders Petra
Ral to take care of the injured soldier
while he takes care of the remaining Titans. After
clearing the immediate area, Levi checks on the
injured soldier, who is quickly succumbing to his
injuries. In an attempt to comfort the scout in
his dying moments, Levi assures him that he has
done his duty well. As the soldier dies, Erwin
arrives and informs Levi that they are returning
to Trost. Levi is unwilling to turn back so soon,
is forced to concede when Erwin informs him
that Wall Rose has possibly been breached.
Levi arrives back in Trost in time to
find two Titans bearing down on four
soldiers at the base of the Wall.
He quickly kills the Titans,
and demands that the soldiers fill
him in on what has happened.[33]
Three days later, after Eren wakes up in the
dungeon beneath the courthouse, Levi assures him
that the higher-ups will let him join the Survey
Corps—and that he himself will make sure Eren does
not get out of hand. Should that happen, Levi
says, he will not hesitate to end Eren's life.
After Eren issues a verbal challenge
to the audience during his trial,
Levi violently beats him on the spot, mockingly
observing that while chained on his knees,
Eren is perfectly placed for his kicks. Armin has
to restrain an infuriated Mikasa from coming to
Eren's rescue and killing Levi. She glares at Levi
after the trial, seemingly unnerving him. Unknown
to Mikasa, the beating was an act in defense of
Eren that gave the impression that despite Eren's
fearsome Titan powers, Levi (and by extension,
the rest of humanity) could still control him.
After the trial, Levi hands Eren over to his
Special Operations Squad for the next month.
They move into the old Survey Corps HQ inside
Wall Rose. Levi orders Eren to sleep in the castle
dungeon so that if he accidentally transforms, he
will not cause problems.[36] During this month,
Hange conducts experiments to try to get Eren to
transform. If Eren goes out of control in Titan
form, Levi intends to cut him out of the nape
in a manner that would sever his human limbs,
which would grow back in any case. However,
Eren fails to transform, and his hands do
not heal from his bites. The Squad decides
to postpone any further experiments.[37]
One day, while having tea with them, Eren leans
over to pick up a spoon and accidentally generates
a partial Titan body. The alarmed Squad threatens
him, and Levi has to defuse the situation.[38]
Levi tells Eren not to take their actions
personally, and that they have good intentions.
Later, after Hange explains why
Eren triggered his Titan form,
Levi's entire squad punishes themselves, and
apologizes to Eren for acting on assumption.
During the 57th Expedition Beyond the Walls, Levi
and his team are ordered to ride in
the safest area of Erwin's formation.
When the formation is suddenly attacked by a
horde of Titans coming at their right flank,
they change course toward the Titan Forest,
and Levi's squad takes the central route.
Once the Female Titan appears, his squad begs
Levi to give them orders, but he continues to
ride forward and look straight ahead. Eren badly
wants to transform and fight the Female Titan,
but Petra and her comrades urge him to trust
them, and Eren hesitates.Levi tells Eren that
he is not wrong for wanting to transform and
that nobody can know the correct choice until
after they have made it. Whatever Eren chooses
to do, Levi says, he should do it and believe
he will not regret it. Eren then declares that
he trusts completely in his squad's victory, and
they keep going through the Forest. This enables
the Survey Corps to capture the Female Titan.
Shortly afterward, Levi gets separated
from his squad. He reunites with Erwin
and prepares to extract the human in control
of the Female Titan from the nape of her neck.
He and Mike attack her and try to cut her hands,
only to discover her ability to harden her skin.
After Erwin orders the cannons to be loaded with
explosives and aimed at the Female Titan's wrists,
Levi, standing on her head, taunts her with
threats of violence, telling her he would like
to face her in her human form over the deaths
of countless of his soldiers. In response,
the Female Titan begins to roar. Shortly after,
Titans come at her from all directions and devour
her. On Erwin's order, Levi and the rest of the
Survey Corps elite try to protect her from them,
but they fail due to the sheer number of Titans.
Erwin orders the Corps to retreat back to the
Karanes District. However, Erwin notes that the
steam from the Titan bodies will make it difficult
for the rest of the Survey Corps to see the signal
flares. He then realizes that the human inside
the Female Titan may have escaped, and he orders
Levi to replenish his gas canisters and blades.
After the Female Titan returns and kills Levi's
entire squad and captures Eren, he and Mikasa
join forces to rescue him. Levi tells Mikasa to
distract the Titan but avoid trying to kill her,
since she is able to harden her skin. Levi then
proceeds to attack the Female Titan, and after
a series of successful attacks, he incapacitates
her. Seeing that the Female Titan is now helpless,
Mikasa disobeys Levi's orders and attempts to
kill the person inside the Titan. However, the
Female Titan swings her hardened fist at Mikasa,
and Levi is forced to pull Mikasa out of the way.
While doing this, Levi injures his left leg. Using
the momentum he gained from the last attack, Levi
then proceeds to cuts through the Female Titan's
facial muscles, causing her to open her mouth
and release Eren. He grabs Eren and flees
with Mikasa, whom he reprimands for having
risked the life of her "special friend"
for the sake of vengeance. As he leaves,
he takes one more look at the beaten Female
Titan and is visibly surprised to see it crying.
As they enter Karanes after retreating, the
Survey Corps receives a hostile response from
the public for their failed mission. Levi is
approached by Petra's father, who reveals that
she wrote to him frequently. He tells Levi that,
as a father, he is worried about Petra's decision
to dedicate her life to him, as she is still
quite young and has her whole life ahead of her.
Levi continues to walk silently ahead
without responding. A few days later,
Eren is summoned to the Capitol for a trial to
decide his fate. Beforehand, Levi, Erwin, Eren,
and the other survivors reunite in the old Survey
Corps HQ. Armin tells them his theory about
the Female Titan's true identity. Levi, still
injured, does not participate in the subsequent
operation in the Stohess District; during this
part of the arc he is only seen with Erwin.
During the supposed breach of Wall Rose, Levi is
seen accompanying Hange and the others as they
head to Ehrmich District while they attempt to get
information from Minister Nick. Though he will not
personally offer them any information, he agrees
to reveal the identity of a person who is able
to speak about the secrets of the Walls: Historia
Reiss. The Shiganshina Trio offer to help locate
her, and in describing her, Mikasa reveals the
name of Ymir—much to Hange's and Levi's surprise.
Levi is briefly seen again at Trost
District, still sidelined due to his injury.
After the appearance of the Armored and Colossus
Titans atop Wall Rose, a detachment of about 100
soldiers from all three military branches is
gathered. Some of the MPs express disappointment
not to have seen any Titans nearby. Levi calls
their bluff by inviting them to join the Survey
Corps any day so they can go outside of the
Walls to fight them, whereupon they back down.
Levi visits Erwin when he is well enough to
talk and expresses sympathy for the loss of
Erwin's arm. Hange and Connie arrive as well
to report on their findings regarding Ragako
village and Hange says that they support the
theory that the Titans were once human.[60]
Levi is initially skeptical because they have
never found humans inside the bodies of Titans,
even living ones, and is depressed to think that
he could have been killing people this whole time.
Hange offers some comfort in that
there is no solid proof of that.
By contrast, Erwin smiles at the
news, which disturbs Levi to the point
he says Erwin is going to make him sick.
Since Erwin is exhausted from his ordeal,
Levi notifies him that he has taken the
liberty of selecting members for his new
Special Operations Squad. He believes that
Eren needs to be pushed into desperation.
Levi, Hange, and members of their squads
retreat to a remote cabin where Eren and
Historia are being hidden. Their objective
is still to seal the hole in Wall Maria,
and if Eren can do that as a Titan it would save
the logistical costs of hauling out materials
like originally planned. When Eren says he is
willing, Levi gives Hange the responsibility
of running the experiments necessary
to test the limits of Eren's abilities.
However, Hange also wants to lay low because
Minister Nick has been murdered. After hearing the
details, Levi disagrees. An enemy that persistent
will find them eventually. He also guesses that
Nick did not reveal any information, as all
his fingernails had been pulled out. Someone
willing to talk, he states, would have given
up after just one. Levi sees two paths forward:
they can either flee before they are stabbed in
the back, or exterminate their would-be killers.
Hange suggests they do both, and Levi notes
that this is exactly what Erwin would say.
After running their experiments, Levi receives
a note from Erwin and asks those members of
his squad "dumb enough" to trust the Commander
to come with him. They manage to escape before
intruders reach their cabin and hurry to their
rendezvous point. When they arrive, they are
approached by a crowd that blame the Survey Corps
for the poor living conditions in Trost District.
In the middle of this, a carriage comes crashing
through and appears to kidnaps Eren and Historia.
However, the kidnapped ones are
actually Jean Kirstein and Armin
in disguise. Levi and his squad track
the kidnappers to their hideout.
They attack the kidnappers before the deception
can be discovered and quickly subdue them.
Their leader turns out to be Dimo
Reeves, the merchant boss who was
blocking the gate with his cargo the day
Trost was invaded. Reeves protests about
not knowing anything and Levi suggests that they
go out and talk. On top of Wall Rose, Levi says
he is not here to lecture him, but
find out about the deal Reeves made
with the Interior Military Police. Reeves
reveals that there was no deal so much as
if his company did not cooperate his employees
would be out of jobs and he would be dead.
Though the Reeves Company does a lot of good for
Trost, Levi recognizes that this will not last and
compares Reeves' fight with the Military Police
to that of the Survey Corps against the Titans.
So that Reeves will fight too, Levi offers to
hand over Eren and Historia on three conditions:
the Reeves Company will work against the Interior
Military Police together with the Survey Corps,
the Reeves Company will trust the Survey Corps
completely, and the Survey Corps will receive
priority access to any luxury goods. It is a hard
bargain, but Reeves agrees and baits Djel Sannes
and Ralph of the Interior First Squad into a trap
so that they can be captured by the Survey Corps.
In hiding below ground, Levi and Hange begin
work on Sannes, who proves difficult to crack,
even after being beaten and having his
fingernails removed to equal the treatment
received by Minister Nick. Sannes expresses some
remorse for the torture he has had to inflict,
but believes it was necessary to
maintain peace within the Walls.
Levi is unsympathetic and suggests
beginning Sannes' torture properly
if he does not answer questions correctly,
starting with the identity of the Reiss family.
Rather than giving in to the torture,
Sannes goads them into tormenting him
further. He knows what it is like to
be the torturer and the power it gives.
Disgusted, Levi suggests they take a break,
and they leave the door open a crack behind
them. This allows Sannes to overhear a staged
conversation between Levi and Ralph, where Levi
claims that Ralph told them everything and Ralph
in turn pretends to have no care for Sannes,
calling him a pain, and asking if there will be a
bed in his cell. Levi adds that if Sannes speaks,
the two of them can even be housed in the
same cell together later. This is enough
to break Sannes and he confesses that the
Reiss family is the true royal bloodline.
Dimo Reeves and his employees are
killed and the murders pinned on
the Survey Corps. While his squad waits in
an alley for their part in the rescue plan,
Levi along with most of Hange's manages to catch
up with the First Interior Squad in town and spy
on the hearse and coffins that they suspect are
carrying Eren and Historia. Levi is disturbed
that the First Squad figured out the Reeves
Company deception, because that would require
thinking like him, or perhaps more like "Kenny
the Ripper." Nifa calls him an urban legend,
but Levi assures her that he is real and
that they lived together when he was a kid.
He notices how the tactics he uses
are strongly influenced by Kenny.
As he realizes this, Kenny Ackerman appears behind
him, wearing vertical maneuvering equipment that
is modified to work with guns for killing humans.
Levi narrowly dodges being shot, but Nifa is
killed instantly. Elsewhere around the stakeout,
Keiji and the goggled soldier are killed as well.
Levi throws one of his blades at Kenny and dodges
his next shot by throwing his cloak as cover.
He makes a break for it, frustrated
that Kenny can read all of his moves
and shocked that Kenny of all people has become
an MP. Members of the Anti-Personnel Control
Squad ambush Levi, using vertical maneuvering
equipment modified for use with firearms, and
he takes cover in a bar to avoid
being shot. Kenny follows him inside.
The two of them exchange barbs about
their past and while Kenny talks,
Levi takes the opportunity to load the
barkeeper's rifle and reposition an
alcohol bottle, allowing him to see Kenny in its
reflection. Kenny figures that Levi joined the
Survey Corps for the same reason he joined the
Military Police. He found something he wanted to
do and hobbies make life worth living. When Levi
asks if killing his soldiers is a part of that,
Kenny admits he will kill anyone if it gets
the job done and says Levi would do the same.
Levi agrees and shoots Kenny by aiming with the
bottle's reflection. The shot hits the chair
Kenny is holding, but is still strong enough
to throw him back outside and Levi takes the
opportunity to escape. He tosses a chair through
a window to distract the squad members outside
before emerging himself and firing a grappling
line into the throat of the nearest one.
The remaining two members nearby prepare to fire,
but Levi uses the dead man as a meat
shield so that he can get in close in
and kill them. He continues to flee and curses
that there are still over ten pursuers left.
Levi catches up with his squad while the
Anti-Personnel Squad is chasing him. He kills
one of the MPs before landing in Armin's wagon
and orders them to stop following the hearse.
Their plan has leaked and now Eren and Historia
are being used as bait to kill them. As they make
their escape, he tells his squad that they
must kill their pursuers whenever they have
the opportunity, but Jean is unable to do so
and finds himself on the wrong side of a gun.
Before Jean can be slain, Armin uses his pistol
to lethally shoot the MP and save his life.
Though Levi's squad escapes intact,
Armin is deeply bothered by the fact
he was willing to kill someone and Levi explains
to him that he was able to pull the trigger
because he knew that if he did not, then Jean
would have died. Jean admits he thought Levi's
way of doing things was wrong, but it was
more that he did not want to hurt other
people. He will fire next time. Levi agrees
that Jean's softness put them in a bad spot,
but he does not know what is right or
wrong and Jean might not have been wrong.
Levi and his squad trap Marlowe Freudenberg and
Hitch Dreyse, who have been sent into the forest
to look for Survey Corps soldiers. They take
their uniforms with the intention of infiltrating
the Military Police to find out where Eren and
Historia have been taken. Before he can announce
their fates, Hitch challenges him over the
civilian deaths in Stohess District and berates
his squad over the disappearance and presumed
death of Annie, who she never really got to know.
Levi corrects her about Annie's true state, in
that she was the Titan hiding in Stohess and
she is currently being held, though that is not
likely a fact they want new recruits to know.
It bothers him that collectively so many people
are in the dark about the truth of their world.
Marlowe asks if the Survey Corps really killed the
people from the Reeves Company and Levi replies
that it was the Interior Military Police, which
causes Marlowe to offer helping him to set things
right. He would be more effective as an actual MP
than Levi's disguised soldiers. Levi is skeptical,
but Jean steps in and asks if he
can handle this. Levi allows it.
Jean tests their character to
see where their hearts truly lie
and when it is clear they have no intention of
killing him or following their original orders,
he believes this is enough to convince Levi
to trust them. Levi and his squad use the
information gathered by Hitch and Marlowe to
attack an Interior Military Police compound.
The infiltration goes successfully,
with the Interior MPs being disabled
rather than killed, but they
do not find Eren and Historia.
Levi and his squad depart with one hostage
who Levi interrogates about their location,
but the MP refuses to talk, instead spouting
off about how the Survey Corps will be lucky
to survive and how Erwin and the other captured
soldiers will be executed. He tells Levi that
their only option is to surrender and hope
that enough to spare their comrades' lives.
Undeterred, Levi asks again where
Eren and "Krista" are located.
The MP is surprised that Levi would give up
on his comrades, but Levi doubts the crown
would spare them and savagely twists and breaks
the MP's arm for not answering his question.
The third time he asks about Eren and
"Krista" the MP is panicked and confesses
that he does not know where they are. Kenny
Ackerman is extremely tight-lipped about it.
Both Levi and Mikasa are surprised to hear the
last name, but they are interrupted by people
approaching on foot before they can question the
MP further. The squad prepares to do an ambush.
However, the newcomers turn out to be Hange
along with Marlowe and Hitch, who have come
with good news. The false charges against the
Survey Corps have been dropped and the capital
is now under the control of Commander-in-Chief
Darius Zackly. Levi's squad celebrates and he
asks what in the world could have been done to
accomplish this. Hange answers that it was the
individual choices of many people that changed
their world. He apologizes for losing Keiji, Nifa,
and Goggles, but Hange finds hope in the fact
that their sacrifice enabled Levi to beat the
First Interior Squad, to which Levi admits that
their leader and his team are still out there.
Hange has a lead though and suspects that Eren
is going to be eaten in order to obtain his Titan
power. Erwin had a report commissioned on the
Reiss estate, and assuming that Eren and Historia
were captured by the Reiss family, that is likely
where they are being held. The day Wall Maria fell
a group of bandits burned down the village
chapel while the Reiss family was inside,
massacring everyone except for Rod Reiss.
Days later he initiated contact with
Historia. Levi concludes that there must
be something special about her bloodline.
The destroyed chapel is what interests
Hange though, because fire should not
have torn down a stone building, and then Rod
Reiss rebuilt the place with his own assets.
There is something strange about all that.
Levi agrees and has everyone head there.
He warns his squad that Kenny will be their
biggest obstacle, because fighting him will
be like fighting Levi himself. Levi asks Mikasa
if she thinks Kenny might be related to her since
they share the same last name, Ackerman, but
she does not directly answer. She only knows
that her father's family was persecuted, and
not the reason why. Levi then asks her whether
she experienced a moment when she felt a sudden
power awaken inside her. Upon confirming this,
Levi tells Mikasa that he and Kenny also
experienced such moments in their lives.
They arrive at the chapel and find
the secret door leading underground.
Levi and the others make preparations for facing
the Anti-Personnel Control Squad, which is waiting
for them below. The group sends barrels of
gunpowder and bags of oil down the stairs,
setting fire to them and filling the underground
chamber with smoke, reducing visibility and
the usefulness of firearms. Most of the squad
exacerbates the problem with signal flares while
Levi and Mikasa Scout out their enemies. Levi
calls for his squad to take them down and the team
springs into action. After a concerted push, they
manage to drive back the Anti-Personnel Squad.
Levi leaves Armin to take care of an injured
Hange while he and the others chase after them.
The squad finds Rod Reiss transforming into
a Titan and Historia trying to free Eren
from his chains. When she is blown back, Levi,
Connie, and Jean take the keys to help free him.
Making matters worse, the roof begins
to collapse from the size of Rod's Titan
and the team is trapped against the wall of
the chamber. Eren is hesitant to act until
Levi pushes him to make a choice, just like he
did back when they were facing the Female Titan.
The memory is enough to get Eren on his
feet. He grabs the "Armor" bottle that
had fallen out of Rod's bag and breaks it
between his teeth as he transforms.[98]
Eren's Titan form then crystallizes, stabilizing
the cavern around the squad, preventing them
from being crushed. Even after he is cut out
of it, his hardened form does not disappear,
which Levi states is a huge development, as
they can now seal the hole in Wall Maria.
Levi and his squad exit the cavern
through a hole made in the ceiling
above and see the trail of destruction
left in the wake of Rod Reiss' Titan.
Armin believes it is an abnormal since it
is ignoring them and Levi tells everyone
that they are going after it. Eren entertains
the possibility of getting eaten by Rod, since
that would turn him back into a human who would
then have the powers of the Progenitor Titan,
but Levi disabuses him of the notion. Even
if they turn Rod Reiss back into a human,
they would still have to undo the First King's
brainwashing in order to get him to help them.
Levi begrudgingly allows Historia to
take part in the attack against Rod,
thinking about the time he threatened
her and told her to fight or run
Erwin meets up with them and Levi briefs him
on the situation. The Survey Corps regroups in
Orvud District in preparation to fight Rod.[101]
At dawn, Historia joins the others on the Wall in
preparation to defeat the gigantic Titan and
Levi tries to convince her to stand down,
but she pushes back using his own reasoning
about choosing whether to run or to fight.
Levi watches the Garrison's cannon attacks against
Rod Reiss, noting how ineffective they are.
When the Titan reaches the Wall, Levi and his
squad move forward with Erwin's plan to cripple
Rod Reiss' hands with explosives and have Eren
shoves barrels of gunpowder inside Rod's mouth,
causing him to explode. The plan is a success
and they begin cutting down the flying pieces
of flesh to find Rod Reiss' true body
and Historia is the one who kills him.
Some time after the fight,
Levi and a subordinate find
Kenny sitting under a tree in the
woods. Kenny is heavily wounded
and Levi sends the other soldier away, saying
he will be fine on his own. As if to mock him,
Kenny shows Levi one of the syringes with the
serum that transforms a person into a Titan.
However Levi knows that if Kenny was inclined to
use it, he would have done so by now. Levi asks
him about the First King and why he does not want
humanity to survive, but Kenny only knows that it
was for that reason that the Ackermans opposed
him. When Levi, now knowing that his last name
is Ackerman, asks Kenny what exactly was he to his
mother, Kenny laughs and reveals that he was her
older brother, thereby making him Levi's uncle.
Shocked, Levi questioned him on why he abandoned
him and is told that the reason he left Levi was
because he believed he was not fit to be a parent.
He gives Levi the serum just before dying as Levi
looked at his late uncle with a solemn expression.
After Historia's coronation, Levi is confronted
by the new queen and the members of the Special
Operations Squad. She punches him,
as Dimo Reeves had told her to do,
and she dares him to retaliate. Instead of getting
angry however, he smiles and thanks his friends.
Two months later, Levi backs up Historia on
providing a home for the poor and orphans,
considering that he was from the Underground
City as well.[107] He is present at Trost when
Hange Zoë is testing out the Executioner
from Hell and attends the military meeting
where Erwin Smith goes over a new expedition
to Shiganshina. In a private follow-up between
the heads of the military, Erwin decides to
entrust Levi with the Titan injection since
he has the highest chance of surviving. It
will be Levi's call if and when to use it.
The next morning, Instructor Keith Shadis is
visited at the training camp by Eren, Hange,
Mikasa, Armin, Jean, Sasha, and Levi. The
reason for this is that Eren now remembers
a past memory where his father Dr. Yeager
met Keith after the massacre in the Reiss
family chapel. Eren asks Keith to tell
him everything he knows about his father,
and they go to a house to talk. Levi
remarks that Keith has changed a lot
since they last met, remembering his head full
of hair and then looking at his now bald scalp.
Keith starts by warning them that he
knows nothing of Grisha's secrets,
but anyway recounts to them all his experiences
with him ever since they met 20 years ago,
until the day of the fall of Wall Maria
after Keith found Eren unconscious
in a forest after receiving the Coordinate. A
furious Hange tells him that he is not the one
who decides if that information is valuable or
not and reprimands him for not saying anything
about it to the Survey Corps before, prompting
Levi to tell Hange to stop. Hange continues to
chastise him and is only silenced when
they are again asked to stop by Eren.
During a meeting with other members of the Survey
Corps, Levi sits silently and listens to Hange
tell Erwin what Keith Shadis explained to them
on their visit. After the meeting is finished,
Levi waits until all the other members have
left and then shuts the door, intent on having
a private conversation with Erwin. He tries
to persuade Erwin to sit out on the upcoming
mission to retake Wall Maria and to leave it
to the others, telling him that in his weakened
state, Erwin will simply be Titan food and that he
is not willing to carry along any extra baggage.
Erwin however explains to Levi that the chain
of command must be preserved, and that he has
an intense desire to see what is in Grisha's
basement, which prompts Levi to threaten to break
both of his legs. However, this does not deter
Erwin and Levi realizes that he will unfortunately
not be able to change Erwin's mind, even
though he fears his death as a wounded soldier.
Late that night at a special 'red meat' dinner,
Levi breaks up a fight between Eren and Jean
by kicking and throwing them both
into submission. He then orders that
they and the rest of the Corps to go back to
their quarters and go to bed. Shortly after,
Eren, Armin and Mikasa talk about their returning
home and Levi listens to them while in the barn.
As he hears Armin's ambitions, his
expression is lowered and darkened.
The next day, just before sunset, Levi
along with the other Survey Corps leaders
salute the higher-ups of the brass,
including Darius Zackly and Commander
Pixis. Levi watches on as the citizens of
the Trost District cheer for the Survey
Corps and call out his name. He acts modest
and calls them selfish before seeing Erwin
cheer back at the enthusiastic civilians.
Right after, the 58th expedition begins,
Levi rides out with the Corps at Erwin's
side as he glances back at Eren and Mikasa.
Near dawn, the Survey Corps walk on foot through
a forest on a mountain, leading their horses.
Levi questions a subordinate, asking if they
are still not at the bottom of the mountain,
worrying that it is almost dawn. As Squad Levi
talk among themselves, Jean spots a Titan and
Hange orders the Corps to halt and illuminate
the area, using fragments from the cave below the
Reiss Chapel. Hange then states that the Titan
is asleep, and the Corps continue. Eventually,
they reach Shiganshina District and ride in on
their horses. Erwin orders the soldiers to be
wary of hidden Titans and then orders them
to switch to vertical maneuvering equipment
and begin the mission. The soldiers leave
their horses and rush toward the gate to
Shiganshina. As Eren arrives atop the inner Wall,
he stares at the ruins of his home town. He is
quickly urged on by Levi to get to the outer
gate and the two take off. As per the plan,
100 soldiers covered by hoods rush to the outer
gate to confuse any watching enemies, making sure
they do not know which soldier is Eren. Hange and
Levi wonder why there are no Titans in the area
and Levi claims that they have fallen right into
the enemy's hands. However, the two agree that
they must go forward with the plan anyway as Eren
flies up above the gate and prepares to transform.
After Eren successfully seals the hole in the
Wall, Levi reminds him that they have to kill all
of their enemies, including Reiner and Bertolt
before their mission will truly be finished.
When Reiner is discovered by one of the Survey
Corps members and attempts to attack Armin,
Levi attacks Reiner, shoving his blade through
the nape of his neck and stabbing him, before
kicking him to the ground. After seeing that
Reiner survived the brutal attack, Levi angrily
laments that he was not able to kill Reiner. While
on the ground, Reiner shifts into his Titan form.
Levi makes his way back to Erwin's side, where the
latter begins issuing commands. He tasks Levi with
helping to protect the horses, believing that
Levi is the only soldier he can trust to take
out the Beast Titan. He arrives first, out of the
two squads sent, and immediately kills two Titans,
ordering the soldiers under his command that
they cannot die. After Bertolt is thrown over
the Wall and transforms, Levi and his soldiers are
bombarded by a barrage of stones and boulders from
the Beast Titan. They retreat to the Wall where
Erwin meets them. Levi asks about Eren and Squad
Hange's well-being, and Erwin informs the soldiers
of their increasingly desperate situation.
As the young recruits fall into a panic,
Levi asks Erwin if he has some kind of plan.
Regarding the situation, Levi gives Erwin
the advice to save as many lives as possible
by "loading them on Eren" to make an escape.
Levi continues by saying that he will fight the
Beast Titan. Although Levi knows that there
is little chance of a victory, he deduces
that there is still hope for the Survey Corps
if Erwin and Eren survive. But for Levi to take
down the Beast Titan, Erwin must sacrifice himself
and his men. At this point, Erwin is melancholic,
but Levi makes the decision and swears that he
will take down the Beast Titan after telling
his commander that he must die for them. In
an attempt to get closer to the Beast Titan,
Levi uses the line of Titans around him to his
advantage while in an open space. To his side,
he notices Erwin's men following closely behind,
fear-stricken as they ride toward their death.
After Erwin and most of the Survey Corps fall
when charging the Beast Titan, Levi takes out
the surrounding Titans and engages Zeke. After
realizing what has happened, Zeke attempts to
crush Levi, who merely dodges, slicing up the
Titan's arm to pieces in the process. Levi then
proceeds to slash the Beast Titan's eyes, blinding
it, then cuts up its ankles which causes it to
topple over. Slicing open the nape, Levi thrusts
his blade into Zeke's mouth, commenting that his
body is heavily damaged after transforming into a
Titan so Zeke can not transform again while he is
busy healing it. Further thrusting his blade right
through Zeke's cheek and above his right eye, Levi
decides he cannot kill him yet, pondering
over whether there are anyone still alive
who he would use the Titan injection on and
have them eat Zeke to steal his Titan power.
However, Levi is interrupted and shocked when the
Cart Titan snatches Zeke and carries him away in
its mouth. Zeke then orders the remaining Titans
to kill Levi, but Levi, remembering his promise
to Erwin, finds his resolve and begins to
take on the Titans and chase down Zeke.
Levi pursues Zeke and the Cart Titan back to
Shiganshina District, where he is stopped by
his lack of supplies. He orders Eren to give him
all his gas and blades so that he can continue the
chase, but Eren panics and demands that Levi
give Armin, who has been mortally wounded,
the Titan injection he is carrying. Levi
hesitates, but agrees. Just as he is about to
hand Eren the injection, a recruit crawls up onto
the roof with Erwin, who is on the brink of death.
Levi decides that he will give it to Erwin
instead of Armin, which enrages Eren.
Appalled at Eren and Mikasa, Levi reminds them of
how important Erwin's survival is, and orders them
not to let their feelings bias their decision.
When Eren refuses to step down, Levi forcefully
punches his face and knocks him aside, before
being pinned down by an enraged Mikasa.
Eren and Mikasa try to convince Levi of Armin's
value, while Floch argues that Levi is correct
to save Erwin, and a fight between them is
only narrowly avoided by the arrival of Hange,
who pulls Mikasa off of Levi. Levi prepares
to inject Erwin, but is given pause by Eren,
who tries to sway Levi by telling him
of Armin's dream to see the ocean.
Levi orders his comrades to leave
him alone while he injects Erwin.
As Levi prepares to inject Erwin, he recalls
Armin's conversation with Eren and Mikasa about
the ocean, and Erwin's dream to see the secrets
locked in Eren's basement. As he begins injecting
Erwin, Levi recalls Kenny's final words about
people becoming slaves to their own desires,
and is surprised when Erwin lashes out
in his sleep, knocking away the syringe.
As he watches Erwin, Levi recalls his order to
Erwin to give up on his dreams and die with the
rest of the Survey Corps' recruits, and the
look of relief on Erwin's face at the order.
After injecting Armin, Levi watches as
Armin's mindless Titan form devours Bertolt,
and explains to a confused Floch that, after all
he has given, it is time for Erwin to finally
rest. Levi attempts to apologize to Erwin
for failing to kill the Beast Titan,
but Hange informs him that Erwin has already died.
On top of the Wall, Levi notices that Armin has
awoken. He fires a signal flare for the soldiers
to regroup. He orders Eren to tell Armin about
the events that occurred in the past few hours.
Armin shows remorse for the measures his comrades
have taken for him, but Levi advocates that he
should not be regretful. Afterward, Levi
follows Eren, Mikasa, and Hange to the
Yeager family's basement. When the group find
that Eren's key cannot open the locked door,
Levi proceeds to kick the door open. They inspect
the basement thoroughly and Mikasa finds a drawer
which needs Eren's key to unlock. Initially
empty, Levi discovers a false bottom and
under it are three hidden books kept intact
with various preservatives. They open the
first book and within it they find an
uncannily realistic portrait of Grisha
standing beside a fair-haired woman and a
child. On the back of it, Grisha had written
that it is not an illustration; it is called
a photograph and humanity has not perished.
While serving their punishment in jail cells,
Mikasa and Eren discuss the journals and
Grisha’s memories until Hange, Levi, and Armin
interrupt Eren and provoke them about what they
were talking about until Levi accuses him of going
through a phase as a teenager and lets them go,
claiming that their sentence is being
cut short because of their low numbers
and their superiors failure to catch the Armored
and Beast Titans. The group, now with Jean,
meet Historia afterward to speak with her after
she finishes reading a letter left to her by Ymir.
After the meeting, everyone, including all
other military commanders and officials,
meet to discuss the recent expedition,
the journals, and the huge loss of life.
Once the information obtained from Eren's
basement is released to the world, Hange
and Levi meet with Roy and Peaure to discuss the
revelations and how the public are handling it.
The royal government plans for the Survey
Corps to be awarded with medals in a ceremony
for their bravery and success. Over hearing a
fight breaking out among the younger recruits,
Levi cuts in to stop them and tell them to
prepare for the beginning of the ceremony.
A military audience gathers in a large room
where Historia presents each of the nine
soldiers with a medal of honor in the form of a
dark bolo tie with the wings of freedom on it.
Months later, in the summer season, Shiganshina
District is once again populated with people as
all the Titans had been cleared out. Finally,
the Survey Corps once again ventures outside
of Wall Maria on an expedition for the first
time in six years. They find a trail left by
a Titan crawling along the ground, and follow
it until they reach the edge of Paradis Island.
Here, the Survey Corps sees the ocean for
the first time. Jean, Connie, and Sasha
begin splashing and playing while Hange gleefully
picks up never-before-seen ocean materials such as
coral much to Levi's dismay, as he attempts
to caution them against touching the water.
One year after the Battle of Shiganshina District,
Levi and other members of the Survey Corps make
contact with the Anti-Marleyan Volunteers,
Yelena and Onyankopon, who rebel against the
rest of the Marleyan crew on their ship. The two
defectors show Levi and Hange their technology,
and Levi is concerned by how greatly Hange is
impressed with Marley's level of advancement.
He asks if the defectors would notify Marley that
they have eliminated all the Titans on the island,
but Yelena says they would not. They are here
under orders from Zeke to free the Eldian people.
Levi attends the military meeting to
decide whether to cooperate with Zeke
and the Anti-Marleyan Volunteers. Though
he does not voice an opinion, he asks Eren
why he withheld the information that he
could control the Founding Titan's power
if he is in contact with a royal-blooded
Titan. Not wanting to disrupt the meeting,
Levi tells Eren they will discuss this later. Once
the Survey Corps agrees to work with Yelena and
Onyankopan, Levi assists them in capturing the
soldiers sent on future Marleyan expeditions.
He later participates in the infiltration
into Marley and the ensuing Raid on Liberio.
After the Jaw Titan sneaks behind and
jumps on the back of the Attack Titan,
Levi takes note and goes to intercept it.
The Jaw Titan tries to bite into the neck
of the Attack Titan, but Levi severs the muscles
in the left side of its face, rendering it unable
to rip out the nape. Then both Levi and Mikasa
engage it, along with many other members of the
Survey Corps. The Cart Titan's Panzer Unit makes
a surprise attack, eliminating many of the Corps
and forcing them to fall back. Noticing the
sudden arrival of Zeke Yeager's Beast Titan,
Levi orders the surviving soldiers to
regroup and stares down the Beast Titan.
Levi is on standby as the Beast Titan sends
debris flying into the surrounding area. He
observes as the Titan calls for him to come out,
and later ambushes it by quickly slicing its nape,
knocking it down. Levi proceeds to
cut Zeke out of his Titan form and,
before grappling away, throws a
bomb into the Beast Titan's nape,
detonating it and demoralizing the Marley troops
with the presumed death of their Warchief.
As the Survey Corps retreat, Levi helps Eren
aboard the airship and then kicks him into the
wall and places him under arrest.He takes Eren
to a back room where Zeke and his attendant
Yelena are. Both he and Zeke exchange
insults when two stowaways are brought
to them; he listens to Hange and
silently agrees when Hange states
that Eren made the entire Paradis Island
a target due to his actions in Marley.
Once they return to the island, Levi rides
into the city in a carriage with Zeke. He mock
threatens to kill Zeke, send his corpse back to
Marley, and then reveal everything about his plot,
which would spell the end for his grandparents.
However, Levi admits as long as Zeke's "secret
plan" is real, he is willing to wait a
little longer before slicing him to pieces.
Levi escorts Zeke to a Titan Forest
with a number of soldiers explaining
that it will not be easy for him
to escape from such an environment.
Zeke asks Levi if he can show the trees to Gabi
and Falco, but Levi responds that it depends on
his own actions. Despite his reservations,
Levi is convinced by his subordinates to
allow them to drink wine imported from Marley
while they are guarding Zeke in the forest.
Zeke later tells Levi about the method he had used
to turn the people of Ragako into Titans. After
the explanation finishes, Levi admonishes Zeke for
his lack of guilt, and tells him that he clearly
has no concern for human life. He is shaken off
and told not to assume how he felt. Zeke changes
the subject by asking when he will be allowed to
carry out his experiment with Eren. Levi tells him
that this is not his call, but both agree that
it would be a mistake to wait around too long.
After a Survey Corps messenger arrives at
the camp, Varis notifies Levi that Darius
Zackly has been assassinated and also
informs him of Commander Pixis's plan
to deal with the Yeagerists. Dismayed to
hear that his friends and comrades have
essentially died for nothing to protect
Eren, Levi tells them they are altering
the plan. He suggests they capture one of
the Yeagerists and force them to eat Zeke;
then when Historia gives birth several months
from now and is ready to inherit, they will
feed the Yeagerist to her. Levi orders Varis
to go inform Pixis and descends from the tree.
Despite the holes in this plan, Levi admits to
himself that he does not care about Pixis's reply.
After trading a few barbs with Zeke, Levi gets
lost in his thoughts. He considers how he will
soon fulfill the vow he made to Erwin during the
Battle of Shiganshina and give meaning to his
deceased comrades. Turning around, he notices Zeke
running into the forest; before Levi can react,
however, Zeke lets out a piercing scream. He
looks on in horror as the numerous Survey Corps
soldiers above him begin to fall out of the trees
and transform into Titans. Levi is caught off
guard but comes to his senses in time to avoid
one of the Titans charging him. Remembering
how his subordinates insisted they enjoy the wine
offered and Zeke's comment on it from earlier,
Levi theorizes that the wine was indeed the likely
cause of the soldiers transforming. Noticing these
Titans are faster and more unpredictable, he
reflects on if his subordinates are still inside
and conscious of their actions. As the Titans
swarm around him in midair, Levi closes his eyes.
Levi slaughters his former subordinates and
collects several Thunder Spears before chasing
down Zeke. Catching up with him, Levi kills one of
Zeke's three Titan escorts and meets Zeke's gaze
with a murderous look. Levi quickly dispatches
another of the Titans before Zeke transforms into
the Beast Titan. As Zeke butchers the final
Titan and throws the bloody pieces at him,
Levi dodges Zeke's attack while chopping up
large tree branches to hide himself in mid-air.
He criticizes Zeke for not anticipating that he
would be capable of killing his fellow soldiers.
Falling towards Zeke, Levi fires and hits Zeke's
nape with four Thunder Spears before quickly
detonating them. Cutting Zeke's mangled and
burned body from his Titan form, Levi insults him
before dragging him out of the forest. When the
tied up Zeke awakens inside a horse-drawn cart,
Levi instructs him to not move, revealing that he
has placed the tip of a Thunder Spear inside his
stomach and attached the fuse around his neck.
Levi chastises Zeke for killing his men, before
starting to cut off chunks of his legs. Hearing
Zeke scream, Levi shouts at him to shut up,
explaining that this has to be done to prevent
him from becoming a Titan. Zeke weakly asks where
his glasses are but Levi brushes it aside,
stating he would no longer be needing them.
While Levi steers the cart, Zeke begins
muttering about his plan to euthanize Eldia
in order to ensure the world's safety. Hearing
this, Levi begins mocking him, saying that
his impending death at the hands of a Titan is too
merciful when considering the lives he has taken.
Zeke weakly protests that he was saving their
children from living in a cruel world, prompting
Levi to angrily prepare to cut off his legs again.
Terrified, Zeke pulls the pin on the Thunder Spear
lodged in his stomach; a shocked Levi is unable
to react and is caught in the resulting explosion.
The two of them are launched from the cart, and
Levi is sent hurling towards a nearby river.
Levi's unconscious body is found shortly
afterwards by Hange and a group of Yeagerists.
When a soldier suggests shooting Levi,
Hange insists that he is already dead,
prompting Floch to request that he
be allowed to check for a pulse.
Before Floch can check, he is distracted by
the sight of Zeke emerging from a nearby Titan,
allowing Hange to grab Levi's body
and dive into the river to escape.
Since he was near Zeke when the Thunder Spear was
activated, Levi's face is severely scarred by the
resulting debris; in addition, Levi also
lost two of the fingers on his right hand.
Levi is eventually awakened from his coma
by a message sent by Eren to all Subjects
of Ymir announcing his intentions to destroy
the world outside of Paradis. The two resolve
to find a way to stop Eren, and Hange creates
a makeshift transport for Levi to be moved in.
As Levi is being transported, they cross paths
with the Cart Titan and a Marleyan general.
Hange approaches the two, insisting
that they and Levi are harmless.[158]
Levi negotiates with the soldiers,
pointing out that they have a common goal
in killing Zeke. Reluctantly, the
soldiers agree to work together.
During the nightfall en route to harbor,
Levi attempts to rest but is awakened by the
commotion being made by the others in the camp.
After daybreak, Levi would stay behind with
the noncombatants as his allies confront
the Yeagerists at the harbor. Having decided to
transport the flying boat to the Marleyan coastal
city of Odiha, Levi and the others head towards
the Azumabito's ship on top of the Cart Titan.
After arriving in Odiha, Armin finds Levi walking
despite his injuries. Levi refuses to rest any
longer and insists on interrogating
Yelena about Eren's next destination.
Yelena claims that Eren is going to Fort Salta,
but Levi is concerned by her sudden cooperation.
As the group prepares to depart Odiha, Levi
prepares himself for battle despite his injuries;
when the others wonder how he will able to
fight with only two fingers on one hand,
Levi brushes their concerns aside and merely
states he will manage fine. He ridicules Hange
for failing to make friends with Pieck, but
becomes concerned when his commander begins
musing about their fallen comrades. Preparations
are interrupted by Floch, who arrives in the
flying boat's hangar damaging its fuel tank,
necessitating repairs. Eren's Titans arrive
as the repairs are being made and Hange volunteers
to hold them off while the ship departs.
Levi stops Hange only long enough to
tell them to dedicate their heart.
As the flying boat reaches Eren it comes under
fire from the Beast Titan. Levi and his comrades
jump from the boat and use their maneuvering
gear to evade the Beast's projectiles before
engaging it directly. The Beast is quickly
defeated, but Zeke is nowhere to be found.
The group decides to retreat to a safe distance
so Armin can transform and try to uncover Zeke
with the blast, but the plan is interrupted when
an army of Titans begins generating on Eren's back
and absconds with Armin. Levi reassures his team
that Armin is unhurt, as he would have transformed
otherwise, and begins devising a plan to act as
bait for the Titans while the rest of the group
tries to save him. Pieck attempts to kill Eren
but is defeated by the Titans, and Levi orders the
remaining soldiers to pursue Armin as he is their
only hope of stopping more Titans from appearing.
The group does not make it far before
Bertolt's Colossus Titan appears.
The Colossus disables Reiner's Titan
and then throws it at the group,
knocking them off Eren's Titan. Levi is
left too injured by the impact to move,
but manages to use the last of his strength
to save Connie from being devoured by a Titan.
However, his leg is caught in the Titan's jaw
and Mikasa is forced to save him. Passing out
from pain, Levi begins to fall and is only saved
when Connie manages to catch him. The entire
group is saved by the timely arrival of Falco,
who has learned to fly with his Jaw Titan form.
A disagreement begins atop Falco's
Titan over whether to attack Eren's
nape or save Armin first and Levi makes
the decision to split up and do both.
Mikasa tries to protest, but Levi insists that
they are no longer in a position where they can
care about Eren's well-being. As his allies
disembark Falco to begin their objectives,
Levi laments the fact that he is too injured
to help. As he reflects on his inability to
carry out Erwin's final order and kill Zeke,
Levi begins to wonder why his comrades all
dedicated themselves to the Survey Corps'
mission. As he remembers his comrades,
Levi asserts that he does not regret
saving Armin's life over Erwin's,
since Armin has always had the same look
in his eyes that his fallen comrades did.
As he observes the battle from Falco's Titan
Levi is perplexed to see a handful of the Titans
begin to defend his comrades from the rest of
the Titans. He is immediately brought out of
his stupor by the sight of Zeke emerging
from Eren's spine and calling out to him.
Without hesitation, Levi decapitates
Zeke before returning to Falco.
The group returns to Salta while Armin transforms
atop Eren's Titan. From the fort they are relieved
to see that Reiner has survived, but are dismayed
to see that both Eren and the source of all
living matter have survived as well.
Connie suggests killing the source,
but Levi insists that they have been
left with no other option than to kill
Eren. Before they can attack Eren
again, the source begins emitting smoke
that billows into the fort. Realizing that the
smoke is going to transform the Eldians present
into Titans, Levi quickly orders Mikasa and Pieck
to leave the fort with him on Falco so that they
are not put in danger by the Titans. Pieck departs
to help Reiner fight the centipede while Falco
takes Levi and Mikasa directly to Eren. Mikasa
deduces that Eren is inside his Titan's mouth
and Levi uses a Thunder Spear to make a
way for her to get inside and kill him.
As the power of the Titans is undone and the
Eldian families begin to reunite with each other,
Levi rests against a rock. He sees
a vision of his fallen comrades
watching him and asks if they were
able to see the result of their work.
The soldiers salute him in response
and Levi returns the salute.
In the three years following the battle at Salta,
Levi takes up residence in Marley. His injuries
leave him permanently wheelchair-bound
and he is attended to by Gabi and Falco.
Thank you guys so much for watching this video,
it really means a lot to us. We will see you
guys very soon in one of our next videos!